Hello, everybody. Dr. Cutters again with section eight of the stop fighting cancer book.
And
Today we're going to talk a little bit about diets in the book you'll find
What I call eedy god's way for cancer, but you need to understand that
That is a general diet. So
When we have a patient in our office we test for specific foods. So I want to make that very clear
I also want to make it very clear that this entire book is a general look at what are possibilities that you can do for cancer
It is impossible for me to write a protocol
And have that published and have everybody fit into that protocol. That's the problem that I see
That's the problem I see with going to an oncologist is that you fit into their protocol. I mean, it's also a problem
I see you going to a Mexico cancer clinic you go to the girls' clinic. Yes, what you're going to get
You're going to get the person protocol. Well, what if that protocol isn't right for me?
Well, you you are fitting your square pegs into round holes and it doesn't work for everybody.
So regardless of what anybody says
One protocol is not going to work for the masses
And I understand the situation. That's what they do. They do chemo radiation and surgery
And you have to fit into their round hole whether you're a square peg or not
So they will hammer you into that hole. Well, it's no different with alternative measures as well
You don't want to take a person and fit them into your protocol. You have to build that protocol around them
So in my training and getting my fellowship and integrative cancer therapy
I learned all the different protocols throughout the years. We went out and did a gerson program
We've done hoxy work. We've done all the different alternative works
We've studied different hyperbaric hyperthermia. That's what I have all these different pieces in my book
However, there is no way in the world that I would suggest even that a cancer patient
Try to do all these things. It's not even possible
So what we do is we do specific testing in our office to find out what is going to be best for that patient
So even though we use a knife machine as I stated in the last section
on everybody
Every single person that's walked out of the door with a knife machine in my office. It's been a different program
So it's very specific to them and their needs
So we try you know nothing's perfect
But we try to meet that person's need as specific as possible so that they're taking as least amount of supplements as possible
And getting the best bag for their bucket across the board for everything
It's the same thing with diet. We want to be as specific as possible
The diet that you see in this written section is a generality and it's a good general diet to follow
However real life in our office we test all the individual foods
Most of the patients we go on a gluten-free diet. I'll tell you off
They're right right off the mat
It's highly inflammatory and even if the person is not gluten-sensitive and there's multiple tests that you can do for that at home
Even if the person is not gluten-sensitive it's still valuable to go gluten-free
My opinion
Everybody in the planet should go gluten-free. It's just a very inflammatory food. It's not the way
That your ancestors ate wheat. It just isn't the same food product anymore. It has been altered and destroyed
So don't come back and say well the eight wheat in the Bible look at
Ruth she picked up wheat in the field said and had and baked bread with it
I'm sorry, but it was a completely different product
It was not the wheat that we have today so you could you're not comparing apples
With apples there. It's completely different. So
Wheat today is just highly inflammatory. It's no good for anything
So you want to stay away from it. That's gluten in general. So that's wheat spelled right
barley and malt and other foods that act like it
When you have a damaged gut border
So that's why you become sensitive foods. So that's why certain foods
are bad for you because they damage your gut border and
They're just acidic for your body and they're just all around no good
So here's a list of things from her offer beauty. I that's a great website if you want to look check out
That website as well
Some top cancer causing foods. Well, maybe I guess I wouldn't phrase it that way do certain foods cause cancer
Well, they contribute so they're contributing factors
So if all I'm eating is McDonald's or fast food or junk food on a daily basis
Then I'm am I going to have a diminished immune response? I can I'm going to have the nutrients that I need to
To sustain a immune response. I'm not going to have the nutrients
I need to live off and myself to live off and I'm going to have
You know a decreased ability to fight off cancer. That's growing inside of us
So remember what cancer is. It's a failure of a cell to go through apoptosis
And now it's in a replication cycle
And this happens in all of us at different times and what keeps one person from getting cancer
And versus another is that their mutability has the ability to kill off that growing mass
So the person never gets a diagnosis of cancer
So your mutability has everything to do with your diet. Your diet is so so so very important
So the diet in this section is really kind of a
A whole food diet learning to eat organic learning to eat foods is close to the way God made them
The even gluten free foods can be very bad for you because they're so highly processed
So you want to go on a whole food type diet
So
That's where we start everybody to better what their process is and we have
Several different trademark diets in our office. What is that?
Edid diet the Edid diet is a plant-based diet, which you'll usually read about what you read about going on a cancer diet
You want to go on a plant-based diet no beats
However in reality, that's a generality in reality
We want to look and test out that person some cancer patients. I want them eating meat
So I don't find into this study said this so everybody has to fit into that study
I buy into what's best for that patient
So we test a person out
So on a number of patients that come to us that have cancer
I want them to eat meat
Some I want at a plant-based diet we call our plant-based diet and eat a diet
Because that's really how we were initially created to eat
We were mad was put in the garden and there were no carnivores
Every was everyone in all the animals were herbivores
It was only after the fall where God gave man a coveted that he would return him to a right relationship with him
The a savior is that we started to eat meat. God was actually the first
person to kill an animal
When he clothed an animal with animal skins and he taught them how to sacrifice
uh
In a covenantial relationship and to be in a walk in a covenantial relationship with him
It hopes for a savior
That being said that's why we call the
Whole food
We have our version of a whole food diet that does include some meats. We call that a coveted diet
So a whole food both of them are whole food a whole food diet that is no meat
We call that an eating diet
Then we go a step further not so much with cancer patients with with a lot with our brain-based patients and autoimmune patients
The step further is when we're really trying to heal the barriers the gut barrier
And the blood the blood brain barrier we call that our
Neomyad diet
That's where you're eating a lot of different fats to heal those barriers
So what diet is right for me?
Uh, well, we just don't know so you're not in my office. We don't have the ability to test you
You'll almost have to just try. It's a trial and error
The best place to start with cancer in my opinion is the Eden's diet going on a plant-based diet
Very little meat if you're going to eat meat start with just maybe once a week or so and make it fish
You're a couple times a week and make it fish
If you're losing a lot of weight you might need a little bit more of that as well
But definitely follow the diet that's in this little in this section of the book
Uh, and use it as far as the whole food part of it meaning that you're eating organic is close to the way as God made it
And little-a-process things as possible is going to be always your best bet
So you look at oh is that how God made it?
That's really important. The other thing I will say in this section make sure that when you're looking at foods to eat you stay
clear as possible of
genetically modified foods
GMO foods
Which you can google search what are genetically modified foods
Go on our website. There's some information on our website if you join our back office cutters clinic
Online there's a ton of information. You're actually could be on a forum where there's a ton of information on GMO foods with a lot of help from a lot of other patients as well
That is probably the most destructive thing to your
Got lighting that you can imagine
GMO foods literally destroy your gut lighting
Um, and that's they really make them so that they're
resisted to
cord borers and the reason why they're resisted to that cord borer
Word as they destroy the gut lighting of that worm and
That's what it does and yet we eat that cord. So make sure you're buying GMO free things
And unfortunately to be live in the world where companies lie and there are some
There are some whistleblower kind of websites out there
What
GMO cord chip
It claimed to be GMO cord chip
Was just found to use GMO foods. It's just crazy, but
There's still in the market and still claiming to be GMO free
So you kind of got to log to some whistleblower sites too to just be more careful
And I can't give you all of those online
on this program now because they may have changed by the time you listen to them but google that
And look at our website for that stuff. Your diet is so so so so so we'll port it
And the biggest thing that people talk about diet with cancer is stayed off sugar
Well, and it's really not just enough sugar. It's stayed off
Carbohydrates they break down to sugar quite quickly
That's why you'll see in the diet section to stay off white potatoes and grains
That's the best thing to do is to go grain free
Remember what is to go to go gluten free and then also to go grain free if you can too
I know it's difficult, but you really need to follow because it really feeds the cancer
So we'll talk about that later sections
All right, enjoy this section and I'll see you next time